[Music]
now that is the way Harry Styles became
a world-famous music star joining forces
with his One Direction band mates but
now he's got a new band of brothers and
Carly still talked to Harry about making
his feature film debut in the new war
drama Dunkirk
we should never surrender you had said
the camaraderie among the soldiers comes
quickly because you guys are all thrown
together how would you compare that to
your experience starting out one
direction when you guys are thrown
together are you able to drop from that
into this performance I'd say this was
probably the the story's a little more
intense you get these deep relationships
it's like okay I'll look after you and
you look after me there are 400,000 men
on those Peaks director Christopher
Nolan admits he didn't know how famous
Harry really was before casting him I
was new to Harry I mean I'd heard his
name for my kids we're in a one
Directioner know I wasn't what I was
seeing was a very charismatic guy but
who clearly had truthfulness and
sovereignty in his ability to perform as
a film actor when I cast Heath Ledger as
the Joker it raised a lot of eyebrows
and caused a lot of comment I have to
trust my instincts and Harry was perfect
for this
[Music]
you